hi everyone
my name is anushari vastava and i'm
excited to talk to you today about the
new
cloud document ai platform let's dive in
to learn more
document ai is google's solution for
understanding documents in what
we consider dark formats such as pdfs
handwritten forms and images using the
power of ai
document ai turns these unstructured
documents into structured
actionable data for example
you could process multi-page handwritten
applications with a form parser
there are also several specialized
parsers
already created so you could be batch
processing tax documents by this
afternoon
with structured data you can fuel better
business decisions
ensure that your data is accurate and
compliant
and use your data to meet customer
expectations
or hey maybe you're just sitting on a
pile of crumpled receipts you want to
digitize
it's easy to get started with our
specialized parsers
or bring your own document type and test
out our form parser
it's all in the new document ai platform
let's take a look
the platform available in the google
cloud console
is where you can create modify and test
out your processors
we'll walk through an example on the
platform and talk about what's going on
under the hood to show you what makes
document ai special
today we'll demo how to parse a driver's
license application
and show you how to integrate it into
your app or service
here is an image of my form you can see
it's been damaged
it's crumpled and just does not have
great image quality
i want to test out what the generic form
parser will be able to extract
so i will create an instance of it here
i intend to use it in my application's
code on more documents
so these variables up here will be
important later let's test it out
you can see the key value pairs
extracted they're now in a digital
format
easy to use so what happens
under the hood when you run a document
through a processor
first doc prep scans cleans and extracts
text from the image
using google ocr which supports over 150
languages
next the word text and visual elements
are used for classification when
required
google uses an ensemble of natural
language models to extract
simple and compound entities
when the entities are related they're
grouped together
last but not least your document is
packaged up in a unified document format
and sent back to you now that we
understand what's going on
let's integrate my processor into my
application
i'm showing some python code today but
we have client
libraries available in several languages
this api is incredibly simple for how
much is happening behind the scenes
all i need is the name of my processor
which i can construct with the variables
from the console
and then just the bytes of the document
or the image
voila now i can expect all the spatial
and text data
back in an easy to use json format
also with all of these key value pairs
it's easy to integrate this data and
other services
storage or visualization tools i might
be using
we're excited to see what you can do
with the power of document ai
get started today and let us know what
use cases you're solving
[Music]